[Music]
hello my name is Julian poo and we are
um we're uh I'm teaching the road to
2000 um I'm going to be showing you some
games that I played in uh in the
Charlotte open um this game is going to
be against Dean iolo who's an
international Master with a USCF rating
of about
2470 um but before we get into that game
I'm going to show you a warm-up position
again um so I played a game over the
weekend against an 1800 and I had an
interesting tactic so we're going to
look at that so Pawn to B3 my opponent
play D5 Bishop B2 C5 E3 Bishop to F5 it
should be noted already black is kind of
played a little weird because combining
Bishop F5 with C5 doesn't make a ton of
sense because in these London system
structures the pawn really ought to be
on C6 such that D5 is adequately
defended I play Knight F3
um this is pointing out that potentially
I would like to go Bishop B5 and Knight
to E5 so my opponent stopped me then I
play Pawn to C4 and here my opponent
played a pretty bad move he played D
captures D4 and then Bishop to C4 and
we'll notice that white has all of his
pieces out basically um except for the
Knight on B1 uh so we are ready to
execute some kind of attack my opponent
play Pawn to B5 and it is white play and
win this is our warm-up
position it is maybe a little trickier
than it seems at first but uh white is
objectively winning already on move
number on move number
six Bishop okay Bishop F7 King captures
F7 Knight to E5 Knight to E5 okay and
the idea on most King moves is to play
what
move so like let's say King EA
back I'm play queen3 right Queen F3
attacks F5 and A8 so if if you play King
to E8 then this is a uh a disaster so
the only in interesting move is King to
E6 and now
what white has a has a nice win
here the problem is if you play Queen F3
right now yeah white is still better but
after Queen D5 takes takes and Knight F7
King E6 pack the Knight is kind of stuck
on h8 right not a lot of squares to go
to so we actually have something
stronger sorry E4 E4 very good Bishop
takes
E4 oh Queen anywhere wins Queen anywhere
wins I don't know I don't know about
that you play Queen G4 You'll Play
Bishop F5 back it's not so
simple chess bunzo has suggested Queen
C2 pointing out Queen anywhere might not
be might not be the best I think Queen
to most places actually isn't very good
Queen F3 Queen H Queen E2 is the most
interesting actually it's better to
start with Knight C3 attacking the E uh
the E4 Bishop if you um take the Knight
on E5 then white has the nice Knight
takes E4 and queen F3 Checkmate which is
very pretty um and if you go back to F5
now we play your queen E2 move and black
is actually just stuck here um white uh
White is going to win a queen basically
by force if we play um King D6 and
there's Knight F7 if we do nothing
there's Knight C6 um there's a nasty
discovery on every Square you uh you put
your King on the um on the F6 Square we
can check you and then check you again
and win the queen on d8 right there's
just a bunch of a bunch of nasty moves
after everything that uh that black can
do okay so that was my game recently I I
like that game mostly because it ended
quickly um but all right let's get into
my game against deao um so what's funny
about this game I'm going to get to this
opening position um I had this uh exact
start uh with all three of my white
games in Charlotte I played G3 Knight F3
B3 and all of my opponents I guess were
keing Indian players um I didn't do a
lot of preparation because parings were
posted 30 minutes before the round
actually started so you can't really do
a ton of prep um I I've played Dean
before um the last time I played him it
was like a very theoretical
Catalan uh which I ended up winning um
but it's funny I had this position in
three different games and we played
three different move orders and one game
I played Knight F3 G3 which is this game
another game I played Knight F3
B3 and then a different game I played G3
Knight F3 B3 so we we achieved the same
position uh three different ways so that
was that was kind of interesting um so
Dean played Bishop G7 I played Bishop B2
castles Bishop G2 D6 so this is
following um my first round game even
against a 2000 player um here white
needs to play the move d4 uh in order to
stop black from going E5 if you let
black go E5 he's going to have uh a very
nice version of these Kings Indian
positions so we played Pawn to D4 and in
my first round my opponent played Pawn
to E5 anyway
which is a mistake so Pawn captures E5
Knight G4 this is a theoretical position
where white is doing very um very well
this is like kind of a trap um I play
Knight C3 against that opponent um I
don't remember his name I apologize um
and the big idea is okay right now you
need to recapture my Pawn because I'm
threatening to take this uh threatening
to take a second Pawn with um uh you
know with the pawn to the good so Knight
takes E5 is maybe the most natural move
Knight takes E5 and you're like well how
how do we recapture do you take with the
bishop or do you take with the pawn take
with the bishop then white plays
something uh kind of shocking we go
Queen D2 and then Castle Queen side and
then White's plan of going H4 H5 is
actually really strong and you don't
really expect this from like a double
fian ketto like setup but White's
position is is really good here um my
opponent in the game play D takes E5 and
this is actually
worse this white to play and
win
Queen takes Queen takes queen as the
start and we can play this move without
seeing anything so far Rook
d8 KN to Knight to B so if you play
Knight B5 um your opponent has Knight A6
and it's not
clear you know what we've achieved like
Black's going to go C6 k kick your
knight
out he's he's kicking right why would
this be
losing arguably why would we be
better because
he
anywhere well I mean if we kick his
Knight out then he's going to get his
rook in eventually right he'll move his
bishop move his Rook no I
mean Knight C7 oh yeah I mean Knight C7
would be great he's going to stop us
from doing that at all
costs so what's the next most forcing
move if not Knight
B5 D Knight D5 okay now Knight D5 is a
better version of Knight B5 because it
also prepares Castle's Qui Queen side so
Knight D5 and here if we play Knight A6
what's the
difference what can we do here that we
couldn't do after Knight
B5 oh you got knight7 check take the
bishop
and yeah exactly and then this is a fork
so black black has lost a pawn and an
exchange um so this position is no good
for black um okay Rook D7 is more in is
more
interesting um and then after the move
Castle's Queen side uh we we have the
same threat of Knight E7 so like if if
you play some random pass move the
Knight E7 is forking the king and the
bishop if you take me I go Rook d8 if
you do whatever it is you do to save
your king after Rook C8 you are stuck
right this is not good for black black
is going to lose to Rook D1 Rook d8
eventually amongst other things I mean
Bishop B7 is a threat in the current
position
so um black should play the move Knight
A6 and then white has a
nice uh a nice tactic
here white to play and you you've played
all these forcing moves that are really
nice and you didn't really need to see
anything up to this point to play them
because they were good positional moves
as well now now you're going to need to
do like a one or two move
calculation
so Knight F6 Bishop takes
F6 takes Rook Bishop takes Rook Bishop
nice Knight F6 Bishop takes Rook takes
Bishop takes Bishop B7 and the A8 Rook
is hanging the A6 Knight is hanging and
this position white is only up one Pawn
the computer evaluates this is like plus
four because um even though we're only
up like one Pawn Black's struck sucks
and my Rook is coming to D1 and you you
just have no compensation for the
weakness and the pawn def the weaknesses
and the pawn deficit um I'm surprised
that it gives it plus4 as well like in
human terms this isn't like a plus4
Advantage this is like a winning
Advantage but not you know nothing like
crazy um okay so that was uh that was
from my previous round Dean played
better Dean played the move Knight D7
first in in preparation um I miss
remembered what I was supposed to do
here which is never good um you're
supposed to castle with white uh instead
I played the move C4 which actually
allows black to play
E5 um but okay it's not like white is
worse or anything I just gave up some
advantage that I otherwise could have
had D captures E5 Knight G uh Knight to
G4 and I know thematically in these
positions you're supposed to respond to
this Knight G4 move with Knight to C3 so
Knight captur E5 takes and he played
Pawn takes E5 because he did not want to
play with this space deficit if you play
Knight takes E5 it's going to be very
uncomfortable for you to um deal with
this uh light squared bishop and also if
you try to move your C Pawn ever the
pawn on D6 might just be hanging so he
took with his Pawn I captured sorry I I
castled um and he played the move uh
Pawn to C6 okay what do you guys want to
do after Pawn to C6
for
oh I am reading uh YouTube chat sorry
but uh I I
was zoned out all right what happens
after E4 instead of Rook D7 Bishop G7
Rook
D5 E4 instead of Rook
D7 Bishop G7 Rook D5 what are we talking
about I actually I'm I'm sorry I don't
know what position you're referring
to
yes just the same Mo Queen C2
Queen bunzo is consistent Queen C2 when
it doesn't ha a queen queen C2 when it's
fine just Queen C2 everywhere what does
bunzo play against the slav queen
C2 uh Queen C2 is all right um put aook
on D you want to put a rook on D1 that
makes sense um I think black has a very
clear weakness here that we should be
aiming to Target what is the biggest
problem in Black's
position sort of high highlighted by his
last move
D6 yeah this square is super weak so I'm
looking
AT3 Knight
E and I'm D6 yeah so um I think there
are
two moves that come to mind those moves
are Bishop to A3 and Knight to E4 as you
mentioned I played one of
them um I think Knight to E4 immediately
doesn't generate like any huge threat
right because um we're not threatening
to go to D6 with Tempo so I think Bishop
A3 is just an improvement so I play the
move Bishop A3 to to put my opponent's
Rook on E8 such that when I go Knight E4
well Knight D6 is a big deal if I play
Knight D6 I'm attacking your Rook I'm
also attacking your Bishop on C8 at
minimum I'm going to win the bishop here
probably probably I'm going to win
something more so my opponent played the
best response which is Queen A5
attacking the bishop on A3 I played
Queen C1 just defending uh the the
bishop I would have liked to play Queen
C2 unfortunately the bishop on A3 is
hanging um I also want I also like bunzo
want to just put a rook on the on the D
file okay my opponent plays Knight F6
what would you guys like to do here with
white I know that there are things
objective white has many moves that are
like pretty good but I like what I did
the best even if the computer disagrees
and it's my class so I can you know I
can spread misinformation that's
fine do whatever I want to
do6 yeah KN D6 is what I did and then
what do you want to do
yeah just just take the bishop and um
yeah I mean you might think I'm really
silly because I played Knight E4 D6 take
C8 but statically okay all black and
white both have all their pieces
developed I now have a permanent
advantage in the two Bishops I think
objectively there was something better
to do I don't even remember what but
this is like just a really easy way to
play with white um and then I think my
next move is also pretty nice
so what would you guys like to do here
with white now that we've achieved this
position
to respond to YouTube chat I'll I'll
take your I'll take your word for it but
I'm a little slow so I'm not actually
I'm still not entirely sure what C7 and
E4 have to do with each
other and no variation was a night like
actually going to C7 right all the
variations we were going Knight E7 C8 or
we were playing Knight F6 Rook D7 Bishop
B7 so I don't know what position I put
the Knight on C7
none of them right I don't
know Bishop back to B2 Bishop back to B2
I considered I thought that was
okay um after Bishop
B2 uh potentially black plays like Queen
D2 maybe actually maybe I should defend
the E5 Pawn somehow D Knight D7 or
something I think what I did was
stronger I was B4 B4 wow yeah um I don't
like that move the reason why is so your
Bishop is like good right after B4 you
made it worse I think this move might be
annoying yeah that's that's the problem
with B4 you know but I W I wanna um so
if I can you know start yeah I want to
address I think the thing that matters
the most in the position is this
relation ship here where this queen is
attacking this bishop and this queen is
defending that Bishop this is an this is
a bad relationship for white right I
want to fix this relationship that's why
bunzo wanted to play Bishop to B2 you
know nice and safe um I was I
was
oh bunzo Was preparing Queen C2 I
understand I had a different
motivation um I think that the two
Bishops work really well in end games um
not not to say that they don't work well
in Middle games but in particular this
style of position where there's like one
open file and not a lot going not a lot
going on the addition of Queens being on
the board doesn't really help white so I
was trying to aim for an end game here
okay then you play
B7 yeah I played the move Bishop to E7
and this also has like a a tricky
tactical point because um you know I I
like my my moves to have like a little
bit of poison in them if Black Goes Rook
D7 then obviously white plays what sequ
was the moves that
win Bishop takes Knight and Bishop to H3
these two things are lined up so my
opponent can't play the desirable Rook
D7 move Rook D4 is really silly I just
play Pawn E3 and then we get to play
bonzo's Queen C2 move
eventually yes uh so my opponent plays
uh the move Rook to
E8 um okay so what did I do here uh
Bishop queen queen to A3 that's what I
did I want queens to be off the board um
he can't really invade to D2 right now I
mean first I mean A7 is is just a Target
um I might be able to play E3 first
maybe I don't care maybe I just go
Bishop B4 and queen A7 and I claim I'm
going to take all the pawns on the queen
side maybe unclear they're they're
probably many wins I figured my
opponent's going to take on A3 and if he
doesn't I will
calculate I just did not believe for a
second he was going to do anything other
than Queen takes A3 opponent played
Queen A3 played Bishop A3 and goes Rook
C to
d8
okay now here um obviously I played Rook
D1 everybody in the world plays Rook D1
here the question is which Rook did I
put on D1 and why the aook the a rook
why because you want to
get yeah so I actually think this is a
really interesting moment I played Rook
fd1 the
reason yeah
sorry uh the reason why I did that if
you put play Rook a D1 it is true this
is the safer move because the bishop is
no longer staring at your Rook on A1
however if we think about it I play Rook
ad D1 where can this Rook go can only go
to E1 right now after Rook fd1 I have
these squares that I can put my Rook on
and obviously C1 is the most useful
Square for that Rook to be that isn't
you know D1 yeah uh because this Pawn is
the furthest advance and uh you just
have more Mobility with your Rook so I
thought Rook fd1 was smart and
realistically there are two pieces on on
this diagonal now I'm not saying I'm not
scared but I I thought that I thought
that it would be okay I you know I
didn't see any reason why a tactic would
happen here right like E4 four okay
whatever Rook C1 Rook B1 somewhere and
um and this bishop can't can't hurt me
right Rook C1 for instance um I mean
honestly there are no scary Knight
discoveries so maybe I can even leave my
Rook on A1 for the for the time being um
he's GNA if you get your if you get your
Rook from A1 and he moves that Knight
moves the pawn and the Knight drop yeah
I mean that that that is also something
the black has to worry about um whereas
if we go Rook a D1 I mean The Rook on E1
isn't like super useful right there's no
tangible difference between The Rook
being on E1 or F1 so I'm basically just
saying you know my Rook needs to be on
D1 I will worry about this piece later
and I didn't I I thought that there were
there were real chances that I would
improve my Rook on on the next turn Okay
so Knight D7 is what he played Knight D7
in my opinion is a really bad move this
is not good
defense um and is now white to play what
would you guys like to do with
white I think I played a nice positional
move
C5 uh okay I do not like this move still
closing yeah you're you're closing up
the bishop and uh again you're giving a
Target right like
C5 Pawn to A5 and the pawn on C5 is like
a real weakness you okay A5 is really
slow Bishop f8 is what White's going to
do then you go B4 then A5
like yeah then this this is a real
problem for
you so I really don't like moves that
make this bishop
worse okay YouTube chat YouTube chat um
uh figured it out Fisher random chest
was the first
one sorry
what Bishop H3 is okay but I mean F5
yeah
um okay so uh Fisher random chest
suggests Rook D2 which is what I played
now if we if we go to this position you
will notice that white and black control
the dile like an equal amount right so I
can't move my Rook up the D file black
can't move his Rook up the D file after
Knight D7 that's not true I use the the
opportunity that black has you know
blunted his Rook on the dile to go Rook
D2 so I can double on you know so I can
control the only open file on the board
so I think Knight D7 is a pretty bad
positional move this is not good defense
um black would have been better off
playing something like Bishop f8 um or
any other like waiting move I Bishop f8
is pretty smart I think because it
forces me to go Bishop back to B2 and
maybe he plays Bishop C5 A5 this this
like style of play okay actually E5 is
hanging in the current position um maybe
maybe e uh okay you can't go E4 here uh
maybe Knight D7
now um but the bishop needs to be on f8
anyway so that we can go we can go pawn
pawn
F6 um but okay Knight D7 uh even if
that's so maybe I thought about it now
may maybe he did this out of necessity I
don't know um but
regardless uh Rook to D2 is a good move
and Rook D1 is coming and black is in
trouble he played Knight B8 I played
Rook to Rook a
D1 he trade uh he did not go Rook
D5 what what
what what what what's happening
here they mess up their
broadcast that is uh not the game I
promise
you okay hold
up he played the move Rook captures Rook
on D2 which is shocking maybe to there
we go all right they had Rook D5 as a
variation I didn't put that in there
that's all them
I recaptured and uh White has a pretty
nice position here obviously it's not
winning yet but I control the only open
file on the board and I have two Bishops
uh which is the only imbalance in the
position so he played Bishop f8 okay
this is maybe the easiest question I've
ever asked you in my life uh do we trade
Bishops or do we keep Bishops keep keep
obviously I would kick you out of the
class if you said Bishop takes f8 you
have the two Bishop Advantage don't
don't get rid of those Bishops Bishop to
B2
uh Pawn to F6 so black is um using his
pawns to fight against the bishop on B2
this is this is how you defend these
positions um I played Pawn E3 I thought
that the pawn um is uh is is going to be
most useful on E3 in general the
principle when you're playing against
bishop and Knight and you have the two
Bishops is you want to put all the pawns
on the same color uh of the bishop your
opponent has um meaning I have a dark
Square Bishop he has a dark Square
Bishop we should be trying to put all of
our pawns on dark squares so I want to
play this A3 B4 C5 plan that you want to
play I just want to do it at a time when
I can you know like defend my pawns
right also play A3 yeah yeah A3 B4 C5
this would be the ideal in fact if my my
opponent did like nothing forever which
is not like this is something you should
expect this position is really good for
white we put all of our pawns on dark
squares the reason for this is Bishops
are likely
to be exchanged and then the resulting
end games where I have a bishop against
the Knight my Bishop will be a good
piece as opposed to a bad piece well you
don't want to do when you have two
Bishops you don't want to put all the
pawns on the same color as your bishop
and then your Bishop sucks and it's like
well you have the two Bishops but one of
your Bishops is a
pawn right so the principle here being
if you play with the two Bishops put
your pawns on the same color
um uh that of uh that of your opponent's
Bishop right so I have my opponent's
dark dark Square Bishop we're putting
our pawns on dark squares okay so I
played Pawn E3 he played King F7 which
is a good move I played King to F1
trying to improve my king it's very
clear what he's trying to do he played
Bishop to C5 uh he wants to go King E7
and Rook d8 he wants to try to trade as
many pieces as possible so that he can
make a draw um Bishop to f8 I played
Keen E2 he can't play Rook d8 yet so he
played Keen E7 and then my next move is
uh is playing against this this ke E7
can you have an idea so white to
play What Would you guys do with
white I think there are lots of good
ideas maybe what I did isn't even like
best
H4 H5 is an idea that's that's very it's
a very legitimate way of
playing um I kind of wanted to do that
um but I played this
um uh fixing idea first I like F4
trading the E5 Pawn for the G3 Pawn now
I actually like what you said um under
normal circumstances but in this exact
position you have to you have to
appreciate tactics so F4 with these two
things lined up um I'm not sure if you
can actually get away with that because
I take take and then maybe maybe F5 here
is the most
annoying pointing out that E3 isn't a
strength it's actually a weakness I'm
going to go King F7 next and E3 is a um
going to going to need constant defense
this is not the
ideal in general though if we could get
this structure F4
E4 I like that a lot like if white black
goes Knight D7 or something E4 we can
generate a pass Pawn the only way you're
going to win these like two Bishop
endgame positions is by generating a
pass Pawn you don't win if this
structure remains static and symmetrical
so this is a good idea just maybe not
the right
execution yeah liability there's the
there's the word I was looking
for what about
A3 A3 um A3 is a good idea I think in
general I didn't play it here because if
my opponent plays
A5 or ordinarily I would meet A5 with
Bishop C3 but I think I think trading
queenside pawns helps
black and now my Bishop can only stay on
this diagonal like my Bishop has to stay
on B2 or the A3 Pawn will fall if I go
Bishop C3 he'll take on A3 for instance
Bishop A5 Knight A6 Bishop B4 is coming
in fact anytime you try to play Bishop
C3 Knight A6 is Black's main response
because we want to trade the dark dark
squared
Bishops um so the queen side can't
really be touched right now
okay I played the move Pawn to
G4 I'm
sorry all right just uh it just seems
weird but I think
it's like I I don't want them to play H5
or F5
really yeah so your main idea is just to
stop them from going H5 and F5 yeah yeah
that's that's a good idea so
positionally it's good because if they
play H5 or F5 they are going to have
some kind of weakness so for instance if
you put your Pawn on H5 I will take and
go H4 and then this Pawn on H5 will need
constant defense that like that's an
option I have maybe I won't do it in
that exact position who knows um you
can't go F5 because E5 is hanging the
reason why I like playing G4 here is I'm
playing directly against the idea of
Rook d8 which by the way black should
probably play any like black should play
Rook d8 here I think but my intention
was to trade on d8 and then go G5 this
was the point of G4 I want to undermine
the F6 Pawn such that I get this past E
Pawn now I was analyzing this game
briefly with uh with Yasser Sahan and
Yasser said oh yeah I would I would have
played this way with black and then we
looked at some some moves and uh I was I
was not at all convinced
that uh that white
has uh good winning chances I think if
black plays well then then black is
doing pretty black is black is fine like
realistically if black plays like y or
sarahan then Black's doing
great
um
anyway no yeah all yeah I put my Pawn on
G5 gaser was like that Square's attacked
I'm going to take it he's never seen a
pawn he wouldn't take in his
life spent 20 minutes explaining how
these pawns were in contact I was like
no yeah that was that was my analysis
with Yer um anyway ah let's get back to
the
game I always hit the down key and then
it goes to the end of the game it's very
very sad okay so my opponent played
Knight D7 back Knight
D7 um is is is a concession so what move
did I play after Knight
D7 the Knight was actually doing
something kind of important on
B8
right Queen side yeah so
how Bishop to C3 Bishop to C3 he doesn't
have Knight A6 in response to Bishop C3
because that moves highly illegal right
so Bish Knight A6 not allowed um we're
we're helping our expansion on the queen
side in fact black has only one move
here to survive um he played the move
Bishop D6 which is smart if you just let
me go B4 and C5 then I'm like I don't
even know what an example of a move that
isn't Bishop D6 let's say that black
plays G5 pretending he wants to fix my
Pawn on a light Square has its has its
merits um I will go B4 and I will go C5
and clamp on the queen side this is huge
positional pressure um okay I will
switch and try to go Rook H1 H4 put my
Bishop on F5 this is the kind of
position that white wants I can even
like try to put my king over here in
advance with like A4 and B5 this is this
is a really nice position for white um
if I play the move B4 here which I did
not do Black's idea I'm I'm sure was to
go Pawn to
C5 and if I take obviously I've given
him the C5 Square this Pawn is a
weakness If he if I push then he's going
to put his Knight on B6 and take the C4
Pawn this is become a weakness so I a
bishop D6 C5 is a very clever idea um
after Bishop D6 I understood my opponent
wanted to go C5 sorry yeah B4 C5 so I I
did something else I don't remember what
I did so we're going to press the arrow
key play Pawn to H4 um I did I couldn't
remember if I played H4 Rook D1 I played
both of those both of those moves for
the same reason so my opponent has
stopped my expansion on the queen side
with this bishop D6 idea although B4
will exist permanently
um uh in in future positions all right
uh man with head of dog I am currently
Julian poo for for
today all right Knight to C5 um again I
don't play Pawn B4 because in response
to this my opponent wants to go Knight
A4 and I can't defend my B4 Pawn anymore
right even if I go Rook C2 or something
he will take and Bishop B4 and this this
is a
disaster so I played the move Rook D1
which has the very clear intention of
putting my Rook on H1 and going H5 he
goes um Rook to
d8 and then I played Rook to H1 again
hinting that I want to go H5 or G5 and
play on the king Insight he played the
move Knight A6 your opponent plays
Knight A6 they are telling you they want
to do something what does black want to
do Bish Bishop to B4
okay all right what do you want to what
do you want to do with
white this game is not live this game
was played in
Charlotte
let just hit the arrow key find out what
I should
[Laughter]
do Arrow key
forward yeah so if you play
G5 um the question the question on every
turn that you suggest is going to be
Bishop to B4 right okay so G5 Bishop B4
what is your
intention King takes F6
B that so yeah so the variation
discussed so far has been G5 Bishop B4
Bishop to B2 but
unfortunately yeah take take Rook D2 is
going to
come
yeah so you you can't the bishop B4
forces the exchange of dark Sor Bishops
because the Rook is going to enter your
position now you could avoid the
exchange of dark Square Bishops by
putting your Rook back on the D file but
that seems a a little silly
right can't you still play A3 with the
idea of bish Bishop A3 then Rook A1
followed by bc6 that's
crazy that's
insane chat has suggest this with the
idea of going Rook A1 to play Bishop
C6 I I don't know about
that yeah I mean maybe you can like take
and take on A7 this this idea isn't
like totally silly but can do better
than
this yeah we definitely won't have time
to go over my other
games it's
unfortunate okay so the
decision that you're faced with is what
do I do on on the king side so we've
suggested G5 the other idea
is H5 right so H5 Bishop B4 do you like
White's
position well you know you could
exchange Bishops and then take his G you
got open for your you got
hang yeah so probably we really like our
position so I played H5 which is
directly playing against Bishop B4 if
you play Bishop B4 I will trade Bishops
take on G6 and go Rook H7 and your queen
side dies that's it I go Rook B7 I'm
going to win the game so my opponent
didn't do that and he played the move
G5 in response to G5 which is the only
thing you can do because otherwise my
Rook was going to invade your
territory is white to play White has a
really nice move
here
credit to Stephen
Adams who came up with a rule that works
you know
yeah vuno knows the
principle to be fair I was also think
okay yeah yeah so I played uh if you
play the move Bishop to E4 let's say
this is not what I played then black
will play Bishop B uh black could play
Bishop B4 uh sorry Bishop B4 is not what
black would do black would play the move
Pawn to H6 and all of these pawns are on
dark squares and we've broken the
principle that I just told you which is
we put all our pawns on light squares
and we have a light Square Bishop it's a
fixed structure we might even have like
a bad Bishop black has no weaknesses
here we can't Target any of those pawns
I mean oh sorry black technically has a
weakness in some end games I go King G6
and I win but like how realistic is that
I have to go there there there through
my bishop and I mean that assumes that
his King can't just go to F7 stopping my
Invasion right so here I played Pawn to
H6 first now his Pawn cannot go to H6 if
he plays the move Bishop uh Bishop to B4
my intention was to trade and then go
Bishop to E4 and H7 is a permanent
weakness that he has to defend for the
rest of the game um an example variation
would be something like Rook h8 which is
terrible this is not how you want to use
your Rooks right your Rook has no
Mobility it's just stuck there defending
H7 I would play your A3 move he would go
back I would go B4 and then C5 and then
I would slowly grind him into dust right
right this position is not defensible
for black this is a weakness I will move
my Rook to this file I will make a
second weakness on the queen Side by
force and that's
it so my opponent lashed out with this
move Pawn to F5 okay obviously I took
his Pawn what what are we doing here
playing something else put our Pawn on
G4 to take F5 yeah yeah yeah I showed
this game to Yasser I didn't even talk
about G takes F5 we were both like yeah
G takes
F5 what else do you do opponent played
King to F6
okay what is your response to King
F6 opponent still wants to go Bishop to
B4
I think you have only three candidate
moves and one of them is really bad and
one of them is really
good the other one is
okay
okay so the candidate move suggested in
chat are F4 and Bishop E4 and E4 those
are the three candidate moves I agree
those are the only moves you have to
care about I will tell you E4 is not the
move E4 is terrible this is this is a
really bad move you are making your
Bishop worse your technically up a pawn
but after Bishop to B4 which forces the
trade of dark Square Bishops you can't
afford to move your Bishop off this off
this diagonal because Rook D2 comes
you're not even going to be up material
if we do this and um after we trade this
Knight is going to be a monster and this
bishop is really stupid my knight is
going there and there right you can
imagine uh you can imagine white getting
checkmated in a really embarrassing way
like this and then Rook D3 we have uh
self-mated this is not not what we want
um I lost a game that way when I was
1900 to like a 2200 I was up like four
pawns and I self checkmated this way so
whenever I see this P like potential
pattern I'm forever like cursed like no
don't plunder that way again Julian um
anyway so E4 is terrible don't play E4
Bishop to e so your choice is between
Bishop E4 and pawn to
F4 which one would you like to to play
and
why okay so Bishop E4 is okay white is
still better I think but if Bishop E4
then you have allowed Black's idea which
is Bishop to B4 F4 is the correct move
because this is a hard counter to Bishop
to B4 Bishop B4 will not happen cuz the
E5 Pawn is
hanging so um people are saying Bishop
E4 is more positional F4 is more
tactical no it's not how chess Works
Bishop B4 is inferior to F4 because F4
is playing against your opponent's idea
like this activates Black's pieces and
Bishop to E4 doesn't care about it I
mean we saved our pawn and white has
some Advantage but now like black has
like a defense if we play F4 we have two
Bishops we want the position to be open
we want to play against our opponent's
kaning so um if he plays the move King
King to F5 here um I think the easiest
way is f takes F takes
E5 yeah this should be the easiest and
after Bishop E5 we have E4
check what am I doing I need to make you
guys do this white to play White to play
and
win
Bishop yeah Bishop H3 King
D6 Rook to D1 this is a bad relationship
right tagged Bishop on E5 is tagged one
Defender one attacker if I kick your
Defender away I'm going to win so um he
has to take the pawn on F4 more or less
because if you take on F5 I think Fe and
you're you're forced to move your Bishop
away but if you move your Bishop away
I'll give Rook F1 check give another
check and um uh you want you don't want
to play this
position um so he he traded on F4 which
is probably correct then he took on F5
okay I took on E5 can black take
back same no you cannot take back you
you have the same same winning mechanism
but Rook H5 is also really simple so you
have more than one way to win a piece so
he played Bishop
B4 okay what do you want to do
want to
play1 yeah Rook F1 we should we should
give this check now while our pawn and
E5 is still defended because these
Bishops are going to be traded um so
we'll use the opportunity while we still
have it to give this check um again when
I analyzed this game with Yasser Yasser
was convinced black SU King E6 and he is
probably correct because this Pawn is
the pawn you should care about it's the
one that's likely to become Queen he
played King to G5 and now was kis cut so
this is pretty bad I traded on
B4 um and well what do you guys want to
do here I think my next
move kind
of yeah shows why white is
winning you have many wins here but
oh man I saw a way I could lose you
could go key3 blundering Knight C2 and
then Rook D4 Checkmate don't do that oh
no wait wait wait so you have can can't
never mind it's really stupid to do this
anyway but you actually have K3 don't do
that fisher random chest says Rook F7
which attacks everything this was my
first
instinct I didn't do that I played the
move Pawn
E6 Kan is cut the pawn is the most
important asset in the
position yeah push him baby I just play
this game exactly the way he as sah one
would would play the game I play King E3
stepping out of Knight C3 he played Rook
to E8 then I played Bishop to H3 the
pawn is now uh defended and my Rook is
coming to the seventh he played Knight
B4 okay of course Rook F7 now now that
the pawn is already on E6 defended
Knight A6 and this move I played I think
is is nice so white to play what would
you guys like to do after Knight
A6 D Rook to D7 you put your Rook on any
of those squares he goes Knight
C5 and now your life has become hard I'm
not saying you're not winning you might
be winning who knows like Rook H7
position might still be winning for
white but you've made your task
difficult your task doesn't have to be
difficult your opponent has played
Knight A6 which is
ridiculous his Knight's no good on A6 he
wants Knight
C5 yeah King D4 just playing against his
Knight I don't care if his Knight goes
to B8 I don't care if his Knight goes
back to B4 I care if his Knight goes
here to try to take my
Pawn he took my he took my Pawn is mean
so I took his Pawn that'll show him King
G6 took his other Pawn play Knight B4 um
white has many wins I decided to go Rook
to B7 he went Rook d8 played Rook D7 so
was going to be my response against any
Rook to the dile checks throughout this
game played Rook f8 E7 um now is the
time he has to put his Rook on the E
file uh if he put puts his Rook
somewhere else I will play Rook d8 so he
has to go Rook E8 exactly
then King C5 now that there's no Knight
D3
check I will take the Knight um if you
go uh Knight to some random Square the
idea was to go King to D6 I mean okay
King C6 realistically also like wins
pretty simply he played Knight A6 um
last opportunity to mess up what do you
guys want to
do don't take don't take if you take
then there's Knight
B8 so so uh that would be that would be
a way you could blunder the game
actually wait a second this is what I
was thinking during the game now I
realized wait wait wait you still win
here why didn't my opponent
resign it's over yeah King F7 there's
Bishop B6 actually never mind um I
played the move King D6 because I just
wanted to defend my guy he played King
F6 we played Rook B7 um playing against
his Knight he played C5 and I think my
next uh
my next move is is nice my next two
moves there was another way to do this
you
know yeah I'm sure there there there
were many wins you probably have many
wins here
also
but um I played the move Rook B6 just
attacking his Knight because I lined up
my Rook with his King and then after
Knight B8 I played discover check
winning his Knight on B8 he played a few
more moves he played King F7 so that the
Rook didn't have to be traded but he
resigned here because I have more
Bishops than him and therefore stand
better so Bishops I had more the entire
yeah I had more Bishops than him
throughout the entire game which is why
I won this game um uh so this was the
only game I played well in this
tournament um well like it was like kind
of a smooth smooth Victory I guess I
beat my 2,000 opponent round one
convincingly um but this this one I
didn't really make that many mistakes
um uh his his the main issue is that he
played this E5 move like super early
then C6 weakening the D6 Square
technically this position isn't that bad
for black um I think when analyzing with
with Yasser um what he told me is that
he would play the move bishop f8 and A5
really quickly and he thought that black
had like pretty reasonable chances to
equalize like not not just like defend
obviously like black has a defens
position even the way that he played
during the game um but to to get like a
a comfortable position where he you even
have chances to play for a one with
black so had my opponent Play Bishop f8
and A5 if I were playing Yer S one I
probably would have
lost surprising to almost nobody uh but
luckily for me my opponent played rook
d8 in this Knight D7 idea with Knight B8
being the intention and here white just
has two Bishops and you control the only
open a file hopefully you learn some
positional ideas um that I used along
the way to put pressure on uh Black's
position um do you guys have any
questions uh about this
game no this is online so yeah yeah so
um if you go to Lee chess watch and then
broadcasts and then start Charlotte open
all the rounds were broadcasted I was on
a dgt board on for every round and then
somehow also lost rating un clear how
that happened I lost one rating point
feay so we went from 22770 to 2269
9 lucky or unlucky
unclear um oh I also play the the last
game that I played where I achieved this
position with white I played against
Graham hor hbits and he played a really
interesting idea here and I lost that
game my opponent played the move Knight
to E4 which is playing against the
bishop on B2 I played C4 and then he
played F5 and he gets like a very
interesting version of a Dutch this is
this is a very interesting way of
playing and black has like great
equalizing chances Graham played great
against me um I at several points during
that game I thought I was like better I
thought I was worse then then then
eventually we we got down to this is the
first time this has happened to me in a
tournament game um I'm playing my moves
and then at some point start thinking
and then I look over at my clock my
clock shows two seconds this has never
happened to me before usually I'm up on
time and my opponent is like like even
when I'm losing I'm up like like a
million years on the clock I look over
at my clock it says 2 second I was like
oh my God I have no idea what I'm going
to do then I made some move it was
horrible lost immediately so um that was
unfortunate for me um but Graham played
Graham played really well against me my
the people who beat me they beat they
played nice which I mean you know that
sucks like losing is never fun but at
least like I didn't like play like
really bad and then just like rolled
over and and die you know I like
resisted resisted my opponents played
well and then I lost which is what you
want to have happen in your tournament
games um okay I think uh uh if you guys
don't have any any more questions we'll
end like two minutes
early um all right thanks for attending
my class for uh uh for the road to 2000
thank you thanks thank
[Music]
you